today we're talking about Google cloud
next I'm Jen person and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news from the safety of
our home Google cloud next on air begins
next week
this digital interpretation of our
annual conference will offer 9 weeks of
programming to help you solve your
toughest business challenges in the
cloud and the best part is you can join
in for free no matter where you are and
at a time that works for you be sure to
register beforehand so that you can
build a customized playlist of the
content you're interested in in the
session catalog you can filter by
speaker topic or industry so you can be
sure not to miss a thing each week
during next we'll be adding a new batch
of breakout sessions you can watch on
demand we've also got a lineup of
digital demos weekly hands-on challenges
and even a unique learning series and if
you need a bit more support you can book
a 15 minute one-on-one appointment with
a cloud expert for the duration of the
event this week in cloud will be
covering highlights and sessions you
won't want to miss each episode we'll
introduce that week's theme and then
give you a preview of some of our
favorite content if you want to read
more about Google cloud next check out
the link any thoughts or ideas leave us
a comment or tweet us and we'll see you
in the cloud
you